you
[Music]
it gives me great pleasure to introduce
two fabulous graduate students from
University of Washington I've gotten to
know them a little bit over time Adams
spent two internships over here and
haven't been able to get him out already
this will be a great talk on information
visualization and they work with Jeff
hair over there who for some of you
might know just been responsible for a
lot of different innovations and
graphics including prep use and flair
and that d3 and now the Vegas series
that they'll be talking about they're
going to be graduating about a year in a
year and a half so they'll be on the
market so this is actually nice to know
so and as I said before for those they
were in here they're gonna be sticking
around through the wildest afternoon so
we can set up some one-on-one talks set
an email and I can schedule that or just
you know come up and talk to me
afterwards okay so thanks very much and
take it away cool thank you so before we
begin our talk I would like to advertise
about our interval study on expertise
data analysis so if you regularly
perform expertly data analysis in your
work and once you contribute to your
research we are looking for people to
participate in our studies and this is
the URL Billy slash you - EDA - study
and I think as you tube forward the
email or to people yeah cool so today we
are excited to present about Vega like a
grandma of interactive graphics in this
top will show the design of the language
and show how you can use it for your
daily work and since we have time please
feel free to ask questions any time to
begin with so we already have so many
tools for creating visualization and one
of the most flexible class of tools for
languages for composing registrations
the example of - in this category
include d3 Vega and ggplot and the
language underlying tools like tableau
since that already many tools why do we
need another
anguish and so need to stop we walk to
first walk through what we like about
these languages and see how we're like
goes beyond these languages to the part
and expressive range of graphics many
popular with strange tools adopt the
idea from the grammar of graphics by Lee
Wilkinson the idea is that just like how
grandma inform us how to compose words
into sentences in English a grammar for
graphics provide primitive building
blocks for composing and expensive rain
of charts for visual encodings this
building blocks include data that we
want to visualize transform like filter
education and building graphical marks
such as bar point area line the
including mapping between data and
poverty of these marks and scales are
function that map data we reuse from the
abstract domains to visual well use like
pixels or colors and finally guides such
as access and legends that we like these
scale functions with these building
blocks - for customized switch station
design such as d3 and Vega offer five
grain control for composing interactive
graphics this can be very this kind of -
can be very expressive but they require
what bolsa Finans some technical
expertise for example creating a bar
chart in d3 require at least a few dozen
line of codes and some level of
expertise in JavaScript in contrast to
support a rabbit exploration but in
terms of exploring data and exploring
different visualization design - such as
ggplot2 and tableau allow more concise
off' occasion by omitting low-level
details such as scale and guidance these
to then infer sensible default for these
omitted properties and allow
customization by letting user or write
default values these - with concise
location are flexible for rabbit
ex-parte analysis however they can be
limited for supplying in trash
in assigning Vega light our mission is
to facilitate expert City data analysis
by providing an expressive yet concise
language to satisfy interactive material
graphics inspired by this previous
language we can I provide a concise
language to express a broad range of
visual encodings in addition we get goes
beyond this grammar this traditional
grammar of graphics by providing
operators for composing multi-boot
graphics we also presenting blocks for
composing interactions using selections
with Vega light all these building
blocks are available in a single unified
language so next part done will first
show you the design of Vega light and
after the showing the design I will
briefly show you how assault how you can
use wiggler as a programming tool and
I'll let don't show you the design
thanks am so when we were creating
visualizations what we have to do is we
have to create a visual representation
of abstract data and this helps us to
amplify cognition the main task of the
visualization designer is then to define
how abstract data should be encoded
visually without having to worry about
low-level details such as scales or axes
or how to draw these take for example
this weather data with information about
the precipitation and wind and
temperature in Seattle this data doesn't
have an inherent visual representation
here I create the table to show you the
data but inherently this data doesn't
have a visual representation so if the
analyst decides that they want to look
at a particular aspect they can for
example create a strip plot of the
temperature and this shows us what the
temperature ranges in Seattle and in
Vega light a single view like this one
here is specified by encoding properties
of marks as I'm explained earlier in the
based on the grammar of graphics so a
strip plot is a visualization where we
encode the value
as the exposition of the tick mark and
temperature here is a quantifiable that
shows a magnitude so in our syntax what
we need to do is we need to specify the
data source and then the mark that
should represent the data and most
importantly we have to define the
mapping of data values to visual
properties of that mark and in our
language we express all of this in a
declarative JSON language and JSON is
very easy to process with common
programming languages and is native to
the web which is why we picked it behind
the scenes the vague alight compiler
reasons about the visualization and
results ambiguity about low-level
details such as the scales and axes and
Edisto with reasonable defaults as you
can see here and emitting these details
allows us to have a more concise
specification these defaults and very
light are designed to follow best
practices in visualization design but if
the user wants to customize it they can
overwrite them so any of these
properties that you see here you can
overwrite for example so going back to
the strip plot it shows us the spread of
the temperature in Seattle but which
ranges from a couple negative degrees to
around 36 degrees Celsius however it
doesn't show us how many days have a
particular temperature so we don't know
whether it's 1 or 10 or more days that
have have this 15 degrees Celsius here
in order to see that we could create a
histogram which shows the number of
Records that fall into particular ranges
in other words a histogram is a
visualization of a distribution so now
the question is how do we create this in
Vega light well in the grammar of
graphics a histogram is a bar chart with
the bars the unlined mark the exposition
is determined by AB int field and the
aggregated count maps to the length of
the bars so let's go back to the strip
plot that we had earlier and transition
to the histogram
first we discretize the temperature data
then we encode the count so in aggregate
as the Y position of the tick mark and
this already looks kind of like the
histogram all we have to do is change
the mark type to bar and now we have a
histogram and yeah so this is how you
create a histogram for quantitative data
and Vega light you could change the data
to a bit different they decided it would
still still work the same way to make
sense of histograms Vega lied used the
binning algorithm which discretize is
the quantity of data in human
understandable intervals beyond that
Vega light also determines sensible
defaults for to parameterize this
pinning in the histogram we bend the x
axis which is a positional Channel
instead of showing an ordinal axis
bigger light actually creates a
quantitative axis as a guide we know
from the visualization literature dating
back to Cleveland and McGill that the
position is also highly discriminable so
we can use a large number of bins to
show the the temperature if your instead
use a non positional channel such as
color opacity or shape then Vega light
generates a legend with range labels so
rather than the the axis as the guide
and it also uses fewer bins because
color is less discriminable we have a
harder time telling apart different
colors it's much easier for us to tell
apart different positions so having a
grammar allows us to reason about the
specification and optimize the visual
output with the grammar we can
incrementally customize the chart as
I've shown you another incremental
customization is to add an encoding to
an existing visualization so for
instance we can add we can encode the
dominant weather type using the color
and then we get a histogram that shows
us what the dominant weather days is for
sorry dominant weather is for days with
a particular temperature by default Vega
light picks
colors that don't necessarily resonate
with what my feelings are about these
color these these weather types so we
can customize the scale domain and range
so that these that are drizzle is more
gray how I feel it with drizzle
so when we edit the color encoding
bakelite automatically stacked the bars
instead of layering them and this is
another example of these these sensible
defaults if it were to because of the
stacking the overall shape of the
histogram is preserved and this is where
you can see here on the right in this
case multiple things are interacting to
do this kind of reasoning the very light
compiler took into account the channel
which was color the mark type which was
bar and a layout transform which is the
stacking and these three components
interacting interacted in a non-trivial
way to create a stack chart that is more
expressive than the bar chart with
overlap just to show you that this or
Vella happens if I change this to a line
you can see that that these parts are
and in fact on top of each other and so
snow would be completely hidden behind
here these other bars the stacked has to
Graham more accurately shows us the data
than the naive version would however
it's still it's still hard to compare
particular bars here for example these
two gray boxes here because they don't
share a common baseline so instead we
could take this history I'm with color
instead of using color we could lay out
all of these bars in space and so now we
create one histogram for each weather
type and it makes it easier to compare
the boxes the boxes here and this is the
first example of layered and multi-view
composition in Borrego light vega light
has a grammar to compose views and makes
them fit to new opportunities and in our
grammar we have developed four basic
operators
the first one you've already seen the
faceting which we just used to lay out
the histograms in space and what it does
is it partitions the data by an ordinal
field and then creates a view for each
of the partitions but facet is the only
operator where each subset gets each
view gets a subset of the data in the
other operators each sub view gets
access to the fault data one of those
other ones is the layering operator
where we can stack multiple views on top
of each other with the concatenation we
can combine arbitrary views and create
complex multi view displays and repeat
is a concise and data-driven way to
concatenate views and as a running
example to go into detail through these
four operators will use this histogram
here that shows the monthly
precipitation in Seattle as my now
Seattle is a beautiful place but we
tried to scare tourists by claiming
there's raining all the time which is
which is of course not true unless
you're in November in December which we
are anyway let's talk about this great
chart so in this chart the x-axis
encodes the date which is grouped by a
month and here we use the special
operator this this fuel time unit which
automatically puts all the days with the
same month into one bin the length of
the bar is encodes the mean or average
precipitation of all the dates that fall
into into a month so with the layer
operator we can plot multiple views on
top of each other and this can be useful
for example to annotate a chart to use
it we first nest the specification under
layer keyword and then we can add
another view or a second specification
to this list of views and now the layer
can show the mean precipitation with a
blue mark and note that in this case
here we only specified the Y location of
this rule mark so that we get an overall
average for the whole year not broken
down by month and Vega light
automatically makes these two layers
share the X and the y axis and they in
this case only the y axis and the rule
spends the full width of the chart and
there's an X at the example of this kind
of reasoning that goes on behind we had
two scenes in the compiler and other
operators the concat and we can take it
we can use it to take a single view like
the histogram now you had in the
beginning and visually concatenated with
another view in Vega let you invoke this
by just wrapping multiple single view
specifications in an array and then nest
them under the concat keyword here we
have the V concat which is for vertical
concatenation we also have a token cat
for horizontal concatenation and a
recurring design pattern that we
identified in these concatenated views
is that we often have the same
specification where just the field is
different like in this case here the
only thing that changed is whether it's
precipitation or temperature on the
under y axis here and because this is
such a common operation we promoted it
to its own operator and we call this the
repeat to use it we start with a
specification specification of a single
view and then that's the specification
and add some parameters first we specify
the list of fields that we want to
repeat over or that we want to create
views for and then we replace the field
referent the field name with a reference
to that repeated repeated data and so
now we create one chart for one chart
for precipitation one chart for the
temperature and one chart for the wind
yes
not right now um but that's something
right now we only let you do that for
field now here it's a keyword because it
automatically lays them out inside into
a column yeah if you call a row
it lays it out in a row and we can
actually take this a step further and do
both at the same time and this lets us
create a view for each entry in the
cross product of these two lists and so
that's why we can create this this chart
which is scatter plot matrix or plumb
for short of course you could create
average you could repeat arbitrary views
but here was a scatter plot and these
plums are very useful to investigate
relationships between multiple
quantitative variables and this can be
for example as part of the dashboard you
see to do that in this or you would have
to do concatenation in that case yeah so
you can use these plums as part of a
dashboard and some of them may even be
composed in desparate so as I said
dashboards can have multiple views and
they can be quite useful to make sense
of larger amounts of data and the
relationships between them however when
you create these dashboards you could of
course create them in bakelite if you
create every view separately you would
have to manually reason about the data
management and how these these charts
fit together or how they are they are
laid out and this is where the grammar
aspect of composition comes into play
until illustrate list let's dissect this
dashboard on the that's you on the Left
so first we have a bunch of single views
we have the the histogram with the
different colored bars and scatterplot
and a bar chart or histogram and the
average line and then what we do is we
can use the facet repeat and layer to
lay them out in space combine or
annotate them into these compose
views the cool thing is inveigle IV can
actually combine these composed views
again using the four basic operators so
for instance we can take the three
layered views on the right and create
them in a data-driven way by repeating a
layer but this hierarchical composition
that's going on here can continue so we
can combine the repeat the two repeated
views with an horizontal concatenation
and then vertically concatenate that
with the fest with the trellis view on
at the bottom maybe I'm stuck what's the
difference between order in addressing
facet is you define if an ordinal field
that you partition the data by and
repeat is just repeat the same view and
every view gets access to the fault data
so when when we when they have this
facet down here every view is one is for
each weather type I understand here
because they are they are very similar
you can think of it one is vertical one
is or so if you could transpose the data
you could use one Operator
here we have to because sometimes data
just has a particular format hmm okay
so whoops so we created this whole this
whole view with a single specification
and because it is declarative vaga light
can actually optimize the underlying
data flow that's below this this this
visualization and in bigger light the in
the JSON format this hierarchical
composition is expressed as you would
expect it you can use the nesaf ocation
in place of any single view
specification bigger LED and
automatically reasons about how data
management about the data management and
how scales and axes should be combined
and these dashboards are a powerful way
to look at multi-dimensional data
however to really interrogate the data
further you want to interact with linked
views and uncover hidden relationships
and let me show you how to do that in
Vega light and this is where the
interaction part comes in
so the basic building block for these
for our grammar of interactions are
these selections and there are the core
building blocks they every selection
defines three or a selection defines
three components first it is the event
was the first thing is the event
processing or how points that are inner
selection are chosen interactively for
example whether it should happen on a
click or on hover then the second thing
is the point of interests which might be
the data tuples or visual elements and
then lastly a predicate function to
determine if a point lies within the
selection or not well let's make this
these selections a little bit more
concrete let's start with a simple unit
specification
that shows a scatterplot for cars
so here the horsepower is on X the miles
per gallon on Y and the points are
colored by their manufacturing origin
the simplest definition of the selection
consists of a name here it's called
picked and a type and then we can use
some conditional logic to change the
color pay the color of the points based
on what is clicked on house is working
the selection type is driving a lot of
the default values here for the
selection so the three components that I
described earlier they are all here but
some of them are in the defaults so in
particular this single selection here is
saying unclick select a single point not
on hover and so yeah when you click them
they they get added to the selection we
can change the type of the selection so
that we can add multiple points to it
now the default says on the first click
select the point and with shift like we
can toggle points in and out of the out
of the selection and like we like with
encoding we can override these these
these defaults so whoops so for example
we can do instead of unclick we can do
it on Mouse hover and now we get this
kind of brushing effect here okay so
besides the selections we also
introduced selection transforms and they
are analogous to these to the data
transformations their way to manipulate
what it means to be in a selection so
let's show you let me show you how these
work here is the single view
specification from earlier and as a data
analyst you might have a question of how
does the number of cylinders
a car has to play into into into a trend
that we're seeing here between
horsepower and and mass per gallon this
kind of negative correlation and so to
look at that we can use the selection
and add a at a projection transform and
this allows us to limit the selection to
one field of the of the data so now when
we're clicking a particular point all
the points that have the same number of
cylinders are highlighted as well and
with this interaction I'm able to see
that there's kind of three groups of
soldiers it's eight at the bottom six of
the mid-range and four at the top but
this sort of direct manipulation with
Mike by clicking doesn't really give me
a sense of how exhaustive I'm looking at
at these points so they may be I don't
know maybe cars with like 25 soldiers
and I wouldn't even be able to see them
unless I supposedly click on them so
besides this sort of direct manipulation
we can invoke a transform and add some
dynamic query widgets to to these to the
interactions that we've added and now
guys so yeah okay so now we're binding
this to a to an input element and I can
do the same clicking and interaction in
this chart above but we can also move
the slider back and forth and see that
there's cars with three and five
cylinders but only very fewer with with
three cylinders so it's kind of hard to
to click on them if you're just using
this and because big alight is is this
declarative specification where most of
the defaults or rare defaults get felt
and automatically is very easy to make
small change and rapidly generate and
evaluate hypothesis in this over this
data
some UI controls is there any support
for theming and you know I can imagine
getting this visualization into a larger
application and then wanting to have
those controls look like the other
elements of petroleum application mm-hmm
so here these are just standard HTML
elements this is just a standard range
in CSS styling yes okay so here in this
example I've added just a few more lines
of additional code so that we can look
in addition to just the effect of the
number of cylinders also the what what
the effect of year is on this and now we
have to and so perhaps luckily for us we
can see that as we're scrubbing on the
on the year that if we're going forward
in times in time cars are becoming more
efficient the time lines are moving up
the scatterplot for moving forward in
time here okay so but all of these
selections transformations and the
selections are part of a grammar of
interaction and there's no templates or
so whatsoever so these are reusable
across a variety of different selection
types all of these components so here
for example is a continuous region
selection and it's called an interval
and now by default it allows me to
select a region in both the X and the y
dimension and so we can create this
brush but I can go ahead and use this
transform to restrict it to a single
dimension here here just the dimension
that's used for X and now we have a
brush that only is can only be moved on
of the horsepower and then we can also
use a bind transform to bind the
selection to a scale function rather
than output input element and so any
guess what happens if we if we do that
binding selection to scale
well this is what happens we can now
let's start to pen and zoom in the
scatterplot and this might feel a little
bit magical but let me unpack what's
what's happening under the hood here
what's happening is that we're
establishing a two-way binding between
the selection and the scales so the
selection is populated by the scale
domains and then the scale domains
themselves are being driven by the
selection and so this is what gives us
this this panning int and to me so yeah
there's this two-way binding and in this
reverse population and as you can see
there's implicitly bigger like creates
this this binding here but you don't
have to manually do this but you could
or cars override it or put it into
different parts of a specification so
all solve this is the interaction all
the interactions that I've shown you so
far have been restricted to one single
view but the reason why we designed
multi-view operators and the grammar of
interaction is because these interaction
techniques are most effective when we're
connect coordinating multiple distinct
visualizations and so I can make I can
use a repeat operator to go from a
single scatterplot like the one I'm
assuming before to a matrix of scatter
plots and now we can start brushing and
linking between all of them and all of
our mat eclis all of the selections work
and in these four sub views and with
these are sorts of selections and
transformations a whole number of other
custom techniques fall out very
naturally I can set up an overview plus
detail for focus plus context
interaction and let me show you what
this might look like so we start with a
just an area chart we have the same area
chart again just with a slightly
slightly taller and then we're adding a
we can add a selection to the upper
chart in this case it's an interval
selection or restrict it to X so we get
the brush
and then we can use that same selection
to change the scale domain of the second
chart and then we get this overview and
detail focus on title and text
visualization it's similar to the other
example where I said that some magic
happens here in this case we split where
the selection is used and where the
selection is defined in two hundred two
separate views its arbitrator text this
is the name of your selection you can
define multiple selections here if you
wanted to okay so as a final example of
what we can do with this interactions
and the grammar of interactions let me
walk to walk you through how to create a
variant of cross filtering across voting
of course being one a very popular
visualization technique so we will start
with a histogram and here in this case
it's it's flight data so this is a
histogram that shows us for the binned
hour how many flights are taking off at
that time then we might repeat the same
chart to look at different variables so
besides our also the delay and the
distance that how far the the flight was
and so we just replaced the fuel with
reference to the column and now if we
wonder what we want to do is have this
some kind of layered interaction here so
first we add a second layer which is
just the same as above but we changed
the color to be this this kind of gold
and now we have two times the same
charts on top of each other so let me
let me just for focus a little bit and
collapse this down so now we can add a
selection to the to the chart which is
again just restricted to X so we have
the brush and we can start brushing in
this charge but nothing happens so far
but we can use the selection then to
filter the data in the other chart in
the in the one with the golden with the
birth and so now what we get is this
cross filtering interaction where the
bar is the golden bars in the other
charts correspond to the data that is
selected by the brush and this is all
you need to get Crossville training
working in in vacant light the cool
thing is what we're talking about here
is 35 lines of Jason in a very
composable manner so we might be able to
just extend this to add another chart
that we can interact with ok so now that
you've seen our language design and kind
of what thoughts went into the creation
of this Graham of interactive graphics
helm we'll show you how you can use the
Vega light and what we've built on top
of it
cool so first let's see how you can use
Vega light as a programming tool kit so
to use Vega light we provide a compiler
that translated a wiggle a vacation into
a low-level suffocation that we also
develop at u-dub you can then use vegas
runtime and create a visualization both
natively on the web or we our server and
render visualization using either canvas
or SVG and because we use the underlying
Vega architecture we also support
streaming data as well and by using a
declarative json syntax we can like and
serve as a file format for authoring and
sharing relation and provide buying
support for different languages for
example to perform analysis in Python
you can use a library called altar which
is developed by Baron Granger and Jake
when the pass without her we can create
a histogram that we have been earlier in
Vega light using a native Python API
that map directly to our Vega lie syntax
this can be convenient if you perform
data analysis in Python and we would
like to also highlight that outers
API is automatic generated from Vega
lights json schema
this means that when we publish my nil
version yet hair team mostly need to
just run that script to update their API
when this approach is not limited to
just Python there are upper projects
that try to wrap regular in other
languages as well in a recent article by
dan saber which compare different Python
data visualization libraries then
concludes that is the one to one to one
mapping between thinking code and
visualization that's his favorite thing
about out there and of course the
underlying really language design and
the author have team themselves also
very excited about our design and
mentioned that they see Vega and Rea
delight as perhaps the best existing
candidates for principle lingua franca
of data visualization and just a few
weeks ago we excited that to build a lab
which is the next generation of the
popular Cupid own notebook wood chips
Vega and big alight by default in
addition to use Vega light directly and
we're Apple AP is we go like can also
enable higher level tools like graphical
user interface application that can let
user create Vega like pots real UI
without writing code directly and we can
even use wiggler as a representation for
visualization recommendation to give an
example of a tool that does boil up this
we would like to show you Voyager which
is station to that document manual
visualization specification with
documentation and the goal for this tool
is to promote bread in ex parte analysis
and reduce tedium for manually specify
in charts and to support this goal we
should use wiggle I to both specify and
use as regular as a model to recommend
vegetation here's the washer interface
and here we are showing a dataset about
cards and with Voyager is a single
unified tool that allow user to boss
surface fire station and also show
recommendation to you sir after loading
the data set without having to create
any rules manually we first saw
univariate summaries so that user can
browse different charts and see that Oh
first let's see summary of different
data feel for example here you can see
that in these days that a lot of car
have even number of cylinders and all
these some type of car have odd number
of cylinders you can also see that this
dataset is quite oh it's from nineteen
seventy to eighty something older than
me at least and user can also use the
drag-and-drop interface to be a specific
view similar to tools like tableau for
example dragging horsepower to the Excel
would create a visualization that shows
a lot of horsepower and under the hood
once you use wiggle light create weight
Eliza fication that map horsepower to
the external and use way the light you
bring the other vegetation based on this
visit five you would also suggest
different type of leader bills to help
analysts discovered glow and variables
and alternative ways to summarize or
encode the data for example up here we
recommend related summary rules and to
do so once you consider the regula
fication of the dot plot above and
determine if we can calculate some
reviews by applying aggregation or
bidding and here we see a plot that show
histogram of horsepower and a plot that
shows mean of horsepower you can
similarly to other kind of thoughts for
example suggesting a parts that show
horsepower with other additional water
bow like horsepower and exhalation
horsepower and displacement or hassle
and mouse work gallon and to give users
more control to create a collection of
wheels manually would you also provide a
walk hard to specify a wiring properties
of the relation collection for example
on the Left we have one Hertz for
worrying
multiple fields if I drag a quantitative
feels while hard to why we didn't create
a gallery of scatter plot showing
horsepower with other quantitative
variables under the hood we also use wig
like you enumerate realization for both
leader the mules and one heart and in
this case for one heart we basically
enumerate different quantitative fields
for the white shadow with all these
different interaction methods and this
can rapidly explore different aspect of
the data set and create specific
vegetation to address their specific
goals and
to cap again when ever users with fight
things manually washer create a wiggle
ISIF occasion and render the plot and
also analyze the intended user provide
from the visual interface and provide
with further recommendation for more
details about different kind of
recommendation and what heart
sophistications as well as the
underlying curly language w on top of
rail icon from passerelle you can look
at our research paper and i'm also happy
to come to give another talk about watch
in detail if you're interested so from
Reuters we have to see that legal I can
be used to support recommendations of
data and visual encoding one area future
work that we are excited about is
applying similar approach to recommend
interactions with Vega lights concise
syntax for composing interaction we can
just add one small targeted changes to
ossification and generate a dharmically
different interaction technique with
this small changes we can easily write a
program to enumerate these pairs of
interaction design for visualization and
recommend interaction techniques as well
to summarize in this talk we have shown
you the design of Vega light which
include building blocks for specifying
single wheels and compose them into
interactive material graphics we have
also showed that we can
that can be used directly as a
programming - but very on the web and
we're other rappers such as Altair in
the addition Riggle I can enable
graphical user interface as well as
recommendation in a system like Voyager
and we are happy to announce that last
Tuesday we released the first production
version of Vega light - which include
all the composition and interaction
features we described in this top and we
also have tutorials and documentation
online at Vega github that IO slash Vega
light and if you're interested you can
start playing with Vega light using our
online editor without the need to
install anything we also provide
auto-completion and some hints for
documentation on the editor and finally
who like to thank contributors to Vega
light and related projects of course not
just to us RJ and Ian hook order the
paper contributes to this project many
people contribute to wiggle eye out
there Voyager and yeah so here are the
top contributors and with that we are
happy to take questions and we also can
[Applause]
so we tons we don't do that inside Vega
Omega lies directly but because you have
many ways to buy data to wait a lot you
can use URL or you can buy data at
runtime which mean that the applications
that you write can do some stamping
before they pass the data to wiggle it
alight and I think one of the next
steps for us is also working on taking
the declarative specifications and
reason more about what what is happening
exactly I think now that we have not
just the visualization but also all the
interactions in declarative way we can
actually reason about where data has to
be and what data we have to update when
users start interacting with a chart so
we think this can be a step to really
have inter-african interactive
applications of a large data which also
actually happens to be kind of my
research area and for applications like
Voyager where multiple really parts at
this face the fact that we realize
declarative one thing that we're
planning to do is try to analyze common
data flow for different parts and reduce
the redundancy when you calculate
application or the transform for
different points yeah the other thing is
just using using aggregation and
actually Daniel and I worked the summer
on on different aggregation techniques
for for visualization and we actually
used Vega and Vega light for the
rendering and I wonder is it possible to
the you know extreme end where you can
pretty much create any kind of so that's
more about the how you would create
these kinds of visualizations or the
specification physics
yeah so so with one of the reason that
we do have beta is to develop
applications like word sure so by having
a model that can use as representation
then you can do any kind of UI you can
be other UI that do things similar but
well in different way or maybe on on
tablet or whatever so the answer is yes
but yeah we obviously have to spend time
to develop the UI it's one example yeah
one example is the library tool okay
which is a tool that Arvind developed
which lets you with the drag-and-drop
interface create Vega specifications and
he's he's now a faculty at MIT and once
he will be in or he will be in for
empower
he's looking at Marvin laughter Larry
yeah III and then they later on Vega one
positive then I rented Vega to which
bakelite one was based on no bigger like
2/3 which is based on bigger three and
actually Aaron started updating Lara to
also use some of the automatic
recommendations of the smart defaults
from bakelite so the new version of Lyra
is actually using Vega light for N and
Vega
but what Aaron is interested in is also
looking at how you can create
interactions by by demonstrating them in
a UI this was a lot of things today okay
yes when you're developing a language
like bakelite you know you picked a
couple of core operations the festive
and the repeat that sort of thing and a
couple of fundamental market types the
bar and the rect encircle how did you
how secure you that you've got them all
for some definition of them all or
ultimately is there a shape to the space
that you've got or is it that you had a
handful of demos and you said that
you've build a language that was good
enough to hit all those demos that's a
great question and I mean we're not
claiming that we covered in more
especially for for things like wait a
life which be a more for aesthetic or
graphics so we don't support like bubble
pack layout for example and probably
wouldn't support that at the waygu level
which is another tool that's lower level
then they're more support for those kind
of things so yeah we don't claim to to
support of that what we try to do is try
to aim for what's more frequently use
things so the story behind Vega light is
that the first version was actually
created to build Voyager 1 that that was
the original reason why we even wanted
this language and then it was a
paragraph in the paper and then we
noticed oh this is actually something
that could be useful beyond just Voyager
1 so that we made it its own library and
added interactions and compositions and
all these things
yeah and M is the official request and
and even better for requests all the
time - uh-oh ggplot tends to be used for
a lot abusing our to generate and know
visualizations that incorporating papers
that means they start styling and a
cooperative a little bit easier than
actually manipulate CSS in this review
things is that you know something that
you guys are gonna look at or have some
but part of this is sort of once you got
this how much can people sort of add to
it yeah we actually we already have that
in in Vega Vega has different vendor s
not just to SVG but also to canvas and
that's why normal CSS rules don't don't
apply but what you can do is you can
apply or you can set these what do they
call not styles but I think yeah in the
config you can define how certain
elements should be what are the default
colors should be what the margins should
be inside yeah so so so the answer is
there are ways to allow me to customize
thought even though what we show in the
talk it's mostly the concise syntax most
of the things in Vega like can be
customizable and even for things that
you cannot customize thirdly in Vega
like because we compile things into
lower-level very classification if you
find a rag use case that we haven't even
them in Vega like yet you can use the
Vega output and customize them to and we
also have theming system to to enforce
that all the exes are or the bomber I
should have 13 color for this crafting
you can create theme using wiggle I and
wiggle as well the renders for Vega just
you guys so there's there were some
people who build a prototype for the
prototype and for WebGL yeah
and then MFD uses Vega for as there is
their format between the front and the
back end and they're thinking about also
building new renderers yeah but I think
for the most part I think the biggest
one that need someone to do would be rep
DL but for fun normal usage we don't
have that big data vision can radish
mostly cover but that yeah i think i
think that's one really exciting part
about vague and very light it's just
this this ecosystem of tools and having
one specification language that
different tools can generate and then
different tools that can interpret this
language or reason about different parts
of that language automatically optimize
parts render it with different tools you
can go from vega light to vega if you if
you need the customization as han
mentioned you can then use that use
vague and very light more or less as
data exchange formats which is also one
of the one of the core design principles
behind vega yeah and i mean know that
for example wikipedia or you support
vega because the fattened is declarative
so you can easily add it to wiki and now
that really nice wiggle i to their
interest in having bigger light as para
wikipedia as well for them it was
crucial that it wasn't general
javascript because they don't want want
people to run arbitrary JavaScript other
people computers for for obvious reasons
and so they're declarative form it was
the perfect abstract way to express this
and we also hope that this could be
applied to other things like
publications maybe where instead of you
having to embed a figure that's just a
an image it could be an interactive
visualization which comes with your
paper and we do use big enough our
papers too so yeah unfortunately they're
not interactive in the PDF anymore so
the language is fine by having a set of
primitive and this primitive interact
with other so so in the way adding
things is need to be a little we when we
add new things we have to be a little
careful because it's not just like add
one thing that standalone like if you
want to add and use d3 library you can
just add anything because your user for
for d3 with writings up menu
but for wiggle I because this premium
would automatically interact with other
things then it needs some careful
consideration when you add things for
extensible part one thing that we are
adding is having ability to have mcclure
like for example if you think about
static or graphic like boxplot box what
basically have the Box part which is
basically a rectangle then you have the
line visually whisker
so having ability to add macro for even
more concise syntax is one thing that we
repent we already have it's a pond maybe
if your question was specifically about
how the language is defined so right now
it is defined by what we write down in
our documentation and by the
implementation but we actually also
generate a JSON schema which says
exactly what our allowed properties for
the language so they described all space
but they are obviously only descriptive
syntax not so much the semantics of
things yeah and and for for JSON schema
if you stop playing be witty big idea
online then if you have something that's
invalid if you warned and why did it
yeah so we right now for both Vega 3 and
Vega lights you don't have animation
inside our language but what you can do
is if you use SVG you can already apply
CSS animations already we do plan to add
animation and then in the I don't know
if there's research specific work but
for decorative animation like for
example d3 sort of try to embed
animation transition into
domain-specific language see
transition is sort of similar in a way
so yeah I guess those are the two that I
know how and as it CSS transition can be
applied to to wiggle I thought as well
if you use SVG and when you say for
example I mean you have a streaming data
and you keep updating a part and you
want C to transition the plot then you
can use but there will also be
interesting to again reason about the
specification and having kind of some
kind of grandma aspect to animations so
that an animation is by default somehow
meaningful but I think that requires
some more thinking to actually make holy
what I was gonna hammer on the first
question a little bit more is that if
you were to drop this into a server
client model where the server's doing
the computation how would you break up a
go so that because you you have like
specification but you want to break it
outs of it somehow it generates do not
bias it all that power bi generates some
sort of data you that it wants
gets it gets it back so Vega is fully
reactive it's a fully reactive system it
has there's an API for adding data to it
updating or removing tuples from from
the data and then it automatically only
updates the parts of the visualization
that need to be updated but if you're
taking your Vega light specification
generating the Vega from it it kind of
expects that all the data is there so if
you want to push some of the trans some
of the computation down you would have
to split up that data flow and have some
part on the service and part on the
client so that's about interactive parts
but if database community is there like
a common data format that I could
compile my request into that any Sun
kind of like back-end server could
manage
are you talking about truly about
statics visualizations not because if
you have interactive if you have
interactive visualizations then an
interaction could effect something so
hard of the of the data bite and you
would have to refine the query on the
interaction and update I actually wrote
a paper about this which I guess I
should say here the DSA a workshop
2013-14 budget okay yeah so they're in
it and it idea of taking you to care of
specification and reason about the data
flow behind it and automatically split
it up and dynamically change where
certain operations are taking place but
that was before we even had a
declarative format of interactions and
visualizations now we have that so I
think now we can actually go and and and
get to that vision and do what you and I
want to do basically to answer your
question a little bit more you give in a
regular application you can write a
program that decouples just the data for
part and then you can execute that there
for part on the server but the tricky
part will come when you have interaction
so you should only decouple the part
that doesn't involve it interaction
otherwise it's gonna be a lot of code
involved but but just if you only want
to exactly transform part that do before
you do interaction you can extract that
to the server and for Vega there's a
dataflow API that you can run the data
flow of Vega without caring about we
show any coding at all or it can be a
bit more nuanced something in between
those two approaches where you send some
data to the client yeah that allows for
some limited set of interactions for
example for the cross filtering you
could send a data cube to declined but
hopefully probably not the whole data
cube because it's too large so maybe you
have stricted through certain dimensions
of the data cube yeah
other questions around that should be
wildcards is that Vega reasoning
I'm doing its own type discovery or is
there some expectation that there's some
schema so yeah so so in Voyager then we
given the input data of you analyze this
schema and allow yourself to classify
the schema and and the the question mark
while hard thing is actually a part of
another language that will be on top of
a bigger light we don't have time to
describe much about it but basically
it's all that's another so that's Vega
at the low level that's Vega like the
compulsory baker-bots Vega and bigger
light describe a single visualization
right but then there's another level of
language this the private collection of
visualization and allow you to sort of
group things and and sorting based on
ranking like perceptual effectiveness
ranking so Wi-Fi is at the label on top
of Vega light or an Alex terms so it was
designed for Voyager but you can use it
to be other application that's not the
thing is called compacity well it's on
different github repo I know a few
colleagues in resource that try to use
it for other purpose all ready for
example I don't know if you know about
the world by Jorge poco he does reverse
engineering vegetation and to do that
too to train his machine learning model
he used compares to periodic generate a
bunch of examples that he knows was form
two so that he can have a lot of
training example to to get basically at
and OCR for which is asian so that's one
application I know that another friend
at I just wrote a try to apply the same
engine more for the national language UI
for Association sort of a program
synthesis system in Aleks terms right
you have a partial program partial
specification and then there's a system
that fills in fills in those holes to
create these more detailed yes big
alight specification
which then get compiled to Bagan so if
there are any other questions I
encourage you to come up and you can
make some time to meet these folks let's
take our speakers
[Applause]